d'une certaine manière mieux on fait
notre travail et plus on est en
difficulté je m'explique
moi j'ai 20 sélections nationales et
plus on développe les pratiques foot en
marchant foot golf Footnet plus je
féministe c'est-à-dire que je double mes
équipes nationales donc mieux on fait du
sport pour tous et plus je perds
d'argent pourquoi parce que sur plus de
20 sélections nationales j'en ai une
qui gagne de l'argent c'est l'équipe de
France A masculine toutes les autres
toutes les autres perd de l'argent et
donc puisqu'on est en transparence j'ai
l'équipe de France féminine qui a joué
une demi-finale de l'Euro en Angleterre
donc une performance sportive de haut
niveau économiquement c'est 2 millions
d'euros en moins pour la Fédération donc
c'est ça la réalité du modèle économique
et c'est pour ça que lorsqu'on bouge des
curseurs c'est important de prendre
avoir en tête cet élément là ça renvoie
à la question des diffusions claires pas
en clair parce que on a un modèle
économique qui est encore une fois comme
je l'ai dit mieux vous faites votre
travail et plus vous êtes fragilisé et
que dans un contexte d'inflation que
vous que vous connaissez évidemment
c'est une partie difficile à jouer